Speaker 1: I got a voicemail that that
sort of plays on this idea, and it's harsh,
but I don't think it's inaccurate. Take a listen.
Speaker 3: Hey, David, it's an issue in Milwaukee.
I just had to contact you after listening to
your story about jury duty. First of all, I agree
the majority of people are really
not competent to serve on a jury.
Why I say this is because the people you described
sound an awful lot like the people I work with
every day. They're great, nice people, but.
The intelligence required. To think through a
guilty versus not guilty verdict and all the
nuances of that. They just don't have it.
Speaker 1: Yeah, I mean, listen,
this is tough because I don't want to make fun
of people, but. The issue, what was at issue in
the jury I served on was, was someone punching
someone else in the face? Self-Defense. And the
judge made very clear there are rules this was
in Massachusetts at the time. There are rules for
what counts as self-defense in the state and you
do have a duty to retreat. And if you could just
turn around and walk away from the situation,
it's not self-defense. And in the jury room,
four of the six people, two just had no clue what
was going on, but two insisted. Now if someone
comes up to you and says something like this,
you punch him in the face. That's self-defense,
man. That's self-defense. And it ended up
being like a six seven hour deliberation
which shocked the judge. It shocked the lawyers.
It shocked everybody. And this was really,
really simple. And so when we think about the
Kyle Rittenhouse trial and we listen to a lot of
the things that were said by potential jurors and
even people who made it onto the jury yesterday,
I know that a lot of people like to say it's
not a perfect system, but it's the best system
we have. You're judged by a jury of your peers.
I'm not saying I have a better idea for how it
should be done, but there's a lot of incompetent
people making what are for others life and death
decisions, not literally in the sense of the death
penalty all the time, but going to prison for 10,
20 years. That's a life and death decision in the
sense of it impacts your life for the rest of your
life. And I don't know any way to put it politely,
but it's a very, very scary situation we have
on today's bonus show. We're going to
hear about producer patch road trip
down to Florida, where he's going to be for the
next couple of months. We are going to hear about,
you know, the protesters, the strikers. Rather,
John Deere striking employees have gotten
a pretty damn good offer from John Deere. It
actually seems like some of these strikes may
be having positive outcomes. We'll also talk
about Pennsylvania offering state employees
five days of paid leave for getting
vaccinated. All of those stories and
more on today's bonus show. Sign up at
joined AFRICOM and get instant access.